[Music]
[Music]
hello what's up everybody I'm riding
solo today my name is Eric Tait
you guys are tuned into GameSpot live
today we're gonna be playing for the
second day in a row called duties
World War two's beta which increased the
level cap to 30 currently there was
rumor that it could go up to 40 there's
a couple of new guns the m1a1 carbine
which is a rifle and then there's also a
sniper rifle not great at sniping but
I'm gonna give it a go just so you guys
can see the m1903 seems pretty good from
the limited amount I've used it and
there's also this the basic training
which is ordnance this was new to
cheaper scorestreaks
as well as the ability to reroll your
crates and there's a new map and there's
one more thing missing which is a
scorestreak mortar strikes are in the
game now so let's give it a go I will
try to play domination there's a new map
which is Achin up my connection has been
interrupted which is good it's how you
start things off what's up friend gamer
II says Erik let's go i'ma try today man
also thank you all for tuning in I
appreciate it hopefully we can get on
this is gonna be real awkward because I
was just playing
he's playing like 20 minutes ago it's
currently out on Xbox one and ps4 I
guess if you are playing tell me if
you're in the game cuz apparently I'm
not clearly
it's weird hopefully you guys have tried
it out if you haven't it's definitely at
least worth trying especially coming off
the backs of like advanced warfare
because now it's back to kind of
old-school Cod where you're just running
running gunning no more secret powers or
anything
LOL is right lord pingu i want to join
the fight just let me join the fight is
so awkward
also just in case you guys weren't aware
we got some big streaming plans next
week we're gonna be doing a bunch of
destiny - obviously that's gonna be
coming out next week we'll see me again
here next week as some of you know I
loves me some destiny for some of you
that don't know well now you know
I love me some destiny alright I'm going
to cancel
try again feel like that was a bad idea
though the one cool thing I will say is
though usually if there was an update or
something it would have updated within
the game it wouldn't back me out
oh the client yeah Doug Nick gums got a
good point if he didn't use smg's you're
at a disadvantage it's pretty tough last
week so he's also talking about last
weekend was a joke with SMGs there's
still a lot of people using SMGs I'm not
gonna lie to me that m1a1 carbines okay
you got to play slower obviously with it
because it's a semi-automatic rifle if
you're gonna want to run and gun with a
rifle right now I'd say use the STG and
otherwise the m1 garand is pretty good
too especially with rapid fire but
alright the other thing I can try doing
if I go back to full camera here oops
hold on the struggles are real right now
when you're by yourself
I was gonna back out of the game
completely and then reopen it and see if
that fixes it so let's try that real
quick close the app it was totally
working like just now so uh some bloke
on the internet says I was dominating
with the Louis nice
Louis I believe is an LMG so if you're
dominating with that that's pretty good
alright we're connecting now which is
slightly better than where we were just
at because I think okay now okay all
right I think I fixed it I hope I think
the new maps I seen favorite smg's crazy
99s why see there's only in one new map
right now which is uh option I think you
can snipe down it actually there's three
it's it's kind of like another one of
those traditional three Lane spots but I
think you can snipe down them I assumed
I will say though a lot of the maps are
that we've seen so far are smaller so
they're smaller so I can see why a lot
of maps so far favor smg's I'm kind of
hoping there's some more medium-sized
bigger maps but we'll have to see
domination on point to hawk obviously I
don't know if I can snipe I'll try using
that I'm primarily gonna try using the
m1a1 carbine and the m1 9:03 the sniper
just so you guys can see the new weapons
hopefully I don't have to switch off of
them I was struggling a bit with the
m1a1 carbine yesterday so I was
dominating with the snipers so you
didn't need an SMG that was James
Cornwall yeah I don't know I don't
really snipe in cod and I haven't I
don't have that like quick scope down at
all so if you see me sniping it's very
called a very counter-strike esque for
me where it's like AWP I don't really
hold my breath that much unless I
they're far away I'll I'll just kind of
like flick it but we'll see all right
we're gonna I guess we're just doing
domination on Gibraltar even though I
said Pointe du Hoc this is an old map
this isn't one of the newer Maps
I think the carbine might be okay on
this map we'll have to see
domination obviously changes things
domination what you guys think mode wise
you guys have enjoyed the most having
played war mode
I don't think there's anything either
Doug nickim says whoops I think is
garbage I see a lot of people okay Phil
feeds with the quick sniping so it's
definitely viable
feels just like yesterday no I'm just
kidding
gotta be positive what's up Jose Garcia
how are you thanks for tuning in I'm
gonna do my best to reach at obviously
and play but today this writing solo so
we'll see how that goes for some reason
I thought my team was while watching our
teammate die
I think we're gonna have to push see
like that one other guy because looks
like like got bi mock the graphics look
a bit better yeah it's like yeah it was
totally guy that I should focus on
you got this bro thanks James I
appreciate the kind words we will do our
best
[Music]
at least we got that guy I don't think
they've changed it yet but they were
saying that they wanted to make it
easier for that guy's got a terrible
name I'm not gonna read it
dude you should get up see oh that's new
how does he have green gas unless that's
a care package I've never seen green gas
what that is
this is 60fps you can't drive any
vehicles in multi you can get into the
fighter-pilot if you get the kill streak
which I have equipped so we'll try to
get that to you guys domination that's
again with the chat got lucky that guy
wasn't very good this is the only time
a lot of buildings so anytime you see
the little markers that looks like it's
blocked off is because they're in a
building or listen says I heard erik has
a pretty impressive German accent that
was already weak it wasn't a headshot
wow we're getting rekt domination Ron
the time to reload yeah I visit sir ooh
I think it's a bad habit
I always tell Rob that he shoot in
please don't why did it slip through the
the other side huh
not like this I was a fighter pilot suck
so obviously harping quit sex bomb
hack it to get to hide on classic out of
balance yeah I got it round I threw it
at the ground I didn't throw it like
towards that angles I don't know not
worth I saw the bomb do you like this
game so far since my face Mathias I like
this pod more than I do
more than I do
the advanced warfare stuff that's for
sure this gun is interesting I'm still
not a huge fan but I just wanted to we
got to show off some of the new stuff oh
I did see me dammit I was like maybe he
thought that I would die here
look links it oh sorry my bad if the
audio is a little loud I'll turn it down
guys using the garand the grant is very
strong if you haven't used it yet that's
why I like in my opinion like you're
gonna be using a semiautomatic rifle as
it is I would use the garand over this
thing
we are just stuck in a hard place
rocket art please okay please get be
crazy 99 saying he definitely likes it a
lot more than infinite warfare as well I
think I read that comment pretty quick
that wasn't verbatim but I need FMJ
could it kill them
so someone could please just take be
come on bro that's like the worst your
teammate sees the guy kill you yes let's
just let this game be over please
wolf Matt - the game looks good but this
isn't a classic Cod that I was high for
it's hard to say we're looking at only a
multiplayer which you know isn't that
different obviously but single-player
could be good you know just really
depends on what what you want it and we
haven't seen the full kind of like set
of maps and stuff so we'll try one more
domination and see how it goes I'm
hoping to get options so that we can
maybe try to snipe a little bit level 30
as mentioned was kind of the cap it was
rumored that the cap for beta at some
point would be 40 and that there was
like a flamethrower maybe that's a kill
streak though but yeah hope you all are
doing great today and that uh you're
enjoying yourselves maybe playing some
cod or just watching cod try to answer
as many questions as I can obviously
trying to check out chat to the best of
my ability we are playing on a ps4
currently for those asking on periscope
thanks for the the viewers on periscope
appreciate it
see I'm in Vietnam can i play this game
I'm not sure net when I haven't played
arguing our dentist force in a while
Anton Anton space Anton this kid this
game is trash bruh I mean if you don't
like it that's all good I mean there's
definitely a demographic of people that
like Call of Duty for me personally I'm
looking forward more to a destiny which
comes out next week I think all that PvE
content etc is really what I enjoy up we
got kicked or that uh server didn't work
out for us DK at 8:00 at Eric you should
use your GameSpot clout to force them to
force Activision to have a PC beta I
don't think I have that much clout
unfortunately my settings are default
right now so three and three that was
Sultan Paul ha asking let's see if I can
get periscope chat open
and definitely try let's see it's open
okay there's chat cool
yes blood assassin 69 destiny or someone
call it destiny personal opinion though
oh we got option which is the new map
but we just don't have enough people
right now tell them you know Michael
Hardy I do know Michael Hardy it's uh
it's OB why does it remind you of any
previous Call of Duty's there's
definitely flavors from other cards I'm
trying to think of a cod that was very
SMG dominated I guess a lot of the cause
I've been SMG heavy though or dominated
Jovan's zero and periscope saying I'm on
the fence with this game early wanted
for single-player yeah I think a lot of
people enjoy the Call of Duty
single-player experience I remember that
one with the Kevin Spacey I think that
was infinite warfare right the one Kevin
Spacey I think Connor murder here was in
that one too that was a pretty good
single-player well most of the time
ecology single-player has been very very
solid so interested to see how this one
goes I'm not sure when full open beta is
blood assassin the only way currently to
get into this one is if you previously I
think it was only yesterday you could
try today too but if you're a Comcast
subscribers you might be able to get a
beta key that way otherwise you had to
pre order to get the beta boom boom pow
they have not released a classified guns
yet still division 4 is the max you can
get to unfortunately zombies is uh was
brought up by John Gill 31 that's also
another good reason to get in this one
this one looks pretty crazy zombie Nazis
so
all right I'm gonna try it it's gonna go
terrible I'm just warning you ahead of
time
so please
go easy on me I'm sorry to my teammates
that I'm sniping good luck to all of us
oh we're gonna get a free one okay let's
go ahead and decent mainly because these
guys are giving me a chance I feel like
I couldn't peek the other way I guess I
could have tried to throw it back back I
still don't have the instinct to throw
it back I don't know if you guys have
been playing what I keep trying to run
away from and I really shouldn't be
oh oh it dips dang it Thanks anvil I
appreciate that right over his head but
only an you had a quick scope that guy
fired it for sure been dead that's all
right though been going alright so far
[Music]
thank you to my teammate who sacrificed
his life this is like a dirty spot right
here if there was ever a hard point
Oh My lordy that guy's like all right of
course I knew I was gonna get that one
the pressure one was like I'm gonna miss
all these easy ones and then hit this
really hard one
oh I got someone through the smoke
though blind-fire are the women named
multiplayer yes I'm playing a woman
right now 31 421 jeiza
okay I gotta channel my Saving Private
Ryan I kill someone to like an ad buy
my team is supposed to clear that out
while I snipe right see what is that
green guess anyone knowing gasses
dang it dang it maybe I should hold my
breath more or I'm overcompensating nope
seems like a player to me I don't know
he killed music gas or something look
like yes maybe there's a new tactical
and I didn't look it up
I should go look it might be a new
tactical
are you secure yeah just bad aim yeah
it's pretty bad am I'm trying I'm trying
I told you I don't really smile trying
to snipe though
[Applause]
hardpoint is secure it's not going
terribly though to be honest I thought
it'd be a lot worse
I supposed to like same Bible verses
right now right that's how that's how
that was it it's a library or he's in
the library it's two different things
[Music]
food is getting overrun need
reinforcements
oh he's right across the way I was
saying you can play on the Hong Kong
store without uh hey why are you guys
smoking when you know weird
you got snipers on your team this is
like you have that side or not bro
all right we did it you do hear the
footsteps in this game pro quo you wear
a headphone it'll be definitely more
advantages to you the mountain division
though that which is a kind of like the
new different classes the mountain
division has silent footsteps which is
the class I'm using right now but that's
the only class I believe that has the
silent footsteps oh sorry I missed some
periscope one sorry about that on the
wave how are the map sizes looking like
so far kind of more small to medium more
like three lanes small to medium size is
usually one shot one kill
cool breeze Sam who is also getting beta
today hope you have fun there I'm trying
to do better Bob I am really I am solo
today though but that was a hard point
we're now on Gibraltar secure I think
I'm gonna go back to the m1a1 it appears
we've forgot to check the tactical
grenade that was my bed will this have
bots in the full game I have no idea if
it'll have bot night sir
oops oh that guy just went to town you
just got triple except we're not on the
hardpoint for whatever reason
I was trying to stab them damn
alright let's hope this one doesn't get
flipped into something you know what it
could fall in that building
so I could rerun a mortgage
I should have picked some that were like
closer to a spawner like where they
might spawn though it was kind of a
mistake all right we got any hardpoint
lock it down
ah they're below that there on top also
I thought we had a guy on the MV now gun
is like my kryptonite I think so far in
the beta of all the stuff that's coming
out
I probably hate this gun the most
I'm so Filipino but the thing is I'm not
Filipino
awkward like how I ran to the doorway
there
yes we got one
awaiting coordinates where are you
coming up on searching for targets down
the middle
that's two definitely can't get across
her that's another two
hotpoint is in enemy hands everywhere
position fighter pilots inbound
I see you in the Barca
oh really guy what do we got
artillery barrage awaiting coordinates
target zone look good how are they saw
on the point
I freaking dropped in artillery on there
Hey
doing work Oh God already felt it coming
like my spite of my Cod sense charge it
didn't do the full-on stab those the
problem I had to manually do it thanks
Chris AC I'm doing alright today I got
to warm up I'm like yesterday where I
didn't really warm up which is a mistake
there's a guy right there buddy
location confirmed now let me stab them
Oh SMG life all right sorry what's up oh
sorry guys it's hard to recap but uh
definitely well canes will you be
playing this weekend uh I don't know
gamespot aka Chivo probably just
relaxing chillin switch to the m1 9:03
alright Joe Joe Joe Joseph eleven I will
do that next round I will switch to the
m1 9:03 I got disconnected from the
server cool we can try a domination sure
all right we're going to the forest damn
oh sure you switch to my winter gear
what's up Jay Daniel how you doing I
hope you're doing well
holy [ __ ] it's Erte with the heart it is
me after all
Ian Brogan heart of the map layouts um I
think they're all right I think they
could be a little bit bigger is what a
lot of people
[Music]
Beata okay
do it behind you ah wait how did I get
shut I got bomb straightening running
bow
why don't secure Anton they need a place
a spawn strafing run in bomb
how did how did you get it oh there's
another guy okay
best player work huh yeah as everyone
has mentioned we're gonna call of duty
World War two on the private beta level
30 it's week two there's new weapons the
m1a1 carbine the m1 903 sniper new
scorestreak mortar strikes domination as
mentioned earlier I'm not huge on
sniping so
[Music]
Rico oh he was waiting for me I was too
slow though trying to do the breathe I
don't think breed is the way to go it
narrows the scope too much
I better off just
[Music]
but
we need smaller melee only maps sure
that's what you want
snipe that guy I knew there's a guy
following me too though
sorry got one of the two
should probably take si
oh we're not doing terrible
I've only died three times no ten and
eight okay I was about to say why are
you torturing yourself that's fine he
said I used to live shooting this one
stream called torture chamber
[Music]
three shots
[Music]
[Music]
bear oh wow I thought we got nightbot in
YouTube now pink I was one saying I wish
there was hardcore in this beta out
there yeah that's fine not going to
happen
I told him this way Arnott Don it wasn't
terrible but it wasn't good
what's up hater Hyder Ali what's up
Danny and CV babushka alright so like I
said wasn't terrible wasn't great but
you know as it goes with sniping
sometimes bring back torture chamber
nope not happening there is a bunch of
people that are out for pax if you guys
didn't know pax is happening in Seattle
we got rapid fire we try that how does
that even work
oh let's get that new map thanks a lot
we could try it again
maybe we steal a like um steal a what
Yuma call it gun like a assault rifle or
something
my key I'm using the m1903 there's no
mk14 in this world war to call beauty
World War 2 beta
do you think they'll add more weapons
and killstreaks surely they will right
if not that'd be enough to make me you
not want this well I am but currently
it's only a beta obviously and we've
only gotten to level 30 I think in
previous Cod's it's like what 50 64
levels so I'm pretty sure there's gonna
be like 2 more probably at least another
two more weapons per class of weapons
also you have to realize that there's
divisions which the divisions have each
if you look at it there's a classified
rifle classify submachine gun classify
have LMG classified sniper classified
shotgun so technically there should be
like potentially even three more weapons
oh I play hard point what do you
dominate looks like we might get the new
map so hopefully we do try to snipe
again apologies if it's tough to watch
my sniping I apologize and just trying
it out try it out anyone else remember
Skyrim mods of the week yeah truck D we
actually had cam and Seb at e3 with us
this year and they helped us run one of
the stages which is pretty awesome to
have those guys back all of those guys
loved working with them they are on
their own now doing I think the
production company is called double jump
in the UK so you could check them out I
think they still do Skyrim mods actually
if you want to check those out
[Applause]
yeah good thing our sniper here meaning
is trying to get B instead of oh what a
read
try to get away from
you're capturing evil
yeah and we got that noscope though
care package other way protect the drops
visit artillery ready for all waiting
fire zone confirmation what they don't
have be about this huge artillery strike
for nothing throw it back Eric you can
throw that back now we have you so
realistic try to noscope didn't happen
there's so much cooling we gotta play
slower we gotta play slower
you're not doing so hot thanks Caleb nip
I know how do you see this night I could
easily do what this guy's doing which is
SMG like what I hear woman screams
because I'm playing a female character
yeah also as I'm the one who's mentioned
if you guys didn't know we go live every
day at 11:00 a.m. if you haven't already
liked and subscribed you should do that
so that you guys get notification of
when we go live also when we make that
hot VOD content like things like history
of reboots
I'm tilted I'm tilted I gotta get going
a little run here what's up Warren oh
okay like to tell you that I rage quit
but I didn't I just got kicked
y'all got Xbox one codes I need one
desperately says Village a fryer
unfortunately we don't have any codes to
give out you can pre-order hope to get
in that way
switch back to heart point well switch
back to the m1a1 all right and at the
end like in the next like 15-20 minutes
I could always switch to one of the more
og guns if we want but oh we gotta check
out that gas I keep forgetting about the
tactical that green gas seems like it
will be pretty good for hardpoint and
domination if it does like effective
people
enemy holds for new hurt
oh come on
that'd be enough it says it kills in
three shots but holy crap yeah this is
probably one you want to go like that
Fang basic training where you get like
feedback of holes
how did he know wow you must have some
hot headphones on cuz he turned on me
enemy holds the hard
bring it that's my fault
ah
I didn't hear the fighter pie
cardboard is an enemy
now look at so hot boys and girls
well we finally got one holy crap
party strike incoming
all right whole team's hadn't worked
what is going on connection please why I
mean I'm glad I guess it saved me but
it's like the second game I've been
kicked out of
hcx Ryan I will pray for Houston it's
obviously a tough ordeal I hope no one
has too much family there if they do I
hope that they're doing all right
it's a tough time definitely
all right join a game where we're
getting off fully dominated sick advance
and take position enemy care package
observe stop their resupply
you're like let's save all of our
killstreaks here for what these new
people join
or disappear
stop their resupply
it's gotta be so damn accurate
yeah he's pretty right enemy care
package observe stop their resupply
why is there always another one I like
how the guy named your CH you trash
comes in to tell me this guy's trash
guys pretty good though
makes a lot of sense
don't get scammed
got him
what's up diving league gaming 101 how
goes it
alright we're gonna check out that
tactical thing real quick there are no
let's see deploy ball lifts into the air
there is a gas grenade there you go
what's this do
device that unleashes a poisonous smoke
screen which blurs the vision and
impairs movement sure we'll put that gas
grenade on everyone all right
try again
I'm the low snow I am playing on ps4
right now I'm here for the carbon
gameplay Raj Garcia will try again right
now carbine m1a1 oh crap I got to be
able to put better perks on it right
okay I don't need a force cope it seems
okay we gotta get rapid fire I think
rapid fire might might help us maybe
that'll save me I'm a big fan by the way
thanks hope you're a big fan of the
channel it's awesome thank you for
tuning in what's up dual Drive I hope
you're having a good day hope everyone's
having a good day happy Friday
all right here we go here we go J Garcia
and one A one
pew-pew oh shoot wesley chan is it uh a
boy from Wong foo foo wesley chan give
him that smoke oh here we both often
died this is awkward
please fine the only way I know how to
get kills stab people I heard it
what's up Taiwan shoot them up I'm
trying to shoot them up
definitely I'm trying like this no
Oh mop them up
yeah go do your thing Tay what's up
thanks for tuning in Wes been a while
man hope you're doing well
hope you sir are doing well are what do
we got
we'll take the glide Bob sure like he
knew I was bobbing able I guess I guess
there's over
Oh how's he not dead what oh crap
not even that guy why are they behind us
care package on the way
given that green Joker gas come on guys
stop playing like a dummy it was going
really well what is the best division
it's really hard to say
what do you want to do airborne let's
just get a suppressor on your SMG which
is different than any other class I just
got rekt Mountain gives you silent
footsteps longer holding of breath if
you want to snipe Mountain or not
Mountain armored I haven't used too much
it's like the LMG class I think like you
could take more like pronation there I
have been feeding though so where it
takes more than three shots it's kind of
silly
guy gets my little nest spot here Oh
I got a triple a grease gun that's it
that was the play of the half that's
kind of mediocre domination secure hold
all positions
Oh so back to divisions infantry allows
you to have three three like perks three
attachments are
waiting target information
care package on the way projected up
there capturing evil
artillery ready for orders waiting
coordinates firing primary better
why totally miss with that grenade holy
crap Oh these killstreaks are still
pretty cool yeah I take RC well add that
I've been able to get some just stabbed
oh I thought you didn't see me Erica I
joined somehow on ps4
oh I was I was gonna go ham and try to
nice that guy Jon Snow I'm your son
Danny as my mom I was sick
they're capturing evil
let me recon aircraft observe
[Applause]
of course as a sniper back-to-back
costumes yeah cheeks 77 kind of solo
today and like I figured if I was gonna
have to ride solo Cod was probably an
easy one to play there's one guy that's
out here probably that juice and gin guy
Diamond League gave me 101 can I send
you a friend request on TSM not like
this
they are slowly coming back which is a
problem obviously resupply
okay yeah I did Muhammad I just used the
sniper earlier we could potentially use
it again here the next round
oh wait a decent we had a decent go
there somewhat highs and some lows I can
give that a sniper though next this next
game here sounds good
diamond how long is this treatment going
as Duggal vana Huson hime hopefully I
said that right but an hour and a half
alright we're gonna play one more match
domination we will use that sniper oh
you know what you probably should ah I
was gonna customize and go winter okay
oh god alright I would try to snipe on
this map it's gonna be tough
I think so one's got a lot more open
spots also just so you know I'm not
great at sniping so be mindful of that
but yeah I've said that multiple times
outro so covering my bases
advance and take position
why why
I hit multiple people as smoke sypro
talks I have played war mode it's fun
mode I like it
[Music]
[Applause]
the joys of SMG life shotgun in sniper
combo my business a bunch of people on
track
cool this is really frustrating but will
persists or we can keep getting spawn
killed
cease fire
[Music]
what's up XO goes nice a cypher talks
glad you got a key on xbox and that
you're gonna hopefully be playing see ya
a zombie should be crazy make sharp
eaters what's my favorite division I
like infantry just because I think
bayonet is a lot of fun so for those
reasons I like infantry infantry
Mountain so far for me but that's
because I didn't get that much time with
airborne so far the reason why
where is this guy too slow good job
getting some solid snipe I got some
pretty pretty generous right now thank
you oh the nose country they're really
slow no scope dreams that only I was
gonna keep talking
enemy care package observe stop there
resupply
he's slow just gotta let it rip
[Music]
Ricola walk we have eyes in the sky I'm
going to go bye Eric bye forever
CNN oh God behind there everywhere
are we winning
why did I switch my sniper buddy
yes I got it all right there you go
the m1 903 is this sniper that I'm using
losing a fight
that's my bad
[Music]
yeah we streamed over watch the other
day we did the news team deathmatch mode
available live servers now
TTR has junker town though so if you're
looking to play that
Bob I can send you an invite later so
all right we're gonna play one last this
next one's gonna be last one so if you
guys have a certain thing that you'd
like to see then we'll try it out
Shawn Peters I actually haven't sniped
with a lot of the other snipers so for
me this is the one I primarily used but
uh this one's pretty good I see a lot of
people use the Commonwealth which is um
the this one a lot of people are using
that seems to have way more accuracy
the Commonwealth also has more shots so
someone wants to watch see war mode we
could eat war mode haven't played war
mode the whole day we can end on a war
mode Genki KY one see if there's any
games though so far not so much up there
you go
and one two one I haven't seen the tommy
gun yet so unfortunately I'm not sure
all right we are playing war mode I'm
going to use the STG just stared at the
door I've had a peek the door
we got an afk guy which is very good
so now we're our Phase two best bet is
to start building these mg nests stop
them from building the bridge piers
thanks man what's your favorite weapon
so far prize it STG or m1 garand
personally no sir my favorite smg's are
fine too
keep the enemy from building so for them
what they need to do is they need to use
smokes here
they don't use smoke we're just gonna
keep yeah there you go any new snipers
these snipers and smokes so as long as
my team is protecting me Wow all right
that guy no words were just snipe reach
for it so far so good
it's gonna be really hard for them to
build a bridge without using this guy's
common wall I was tagging them too might
be worthwhile
this is what sucks for them to have to
to fight against so like sometimes not
being like some other guys should
honestly be on the turret and just like
using that kind of throw grenades
everywhere dude it says very alright
crazy rabbit saw me to throw grenades
everywhere
[Music]
it's so hard for them to take this point
easier snap when they have to grab
something but thank you amble it's a pro
would I do it
oh that's now I think if depending on
yeah we got switch sides now so I'm
gonna have to go that their default one
on the second part just to just to try
to build a bridge I'm gonna die a lot to
try to build distributed
I usually just keep smoking and keep
diving just a joke I have a feeling that
we're gonna have the same kind of
problems we just had ourselves
Matthew Clark I should be available on
Xbox ready it was available as of
yesterday so if you have a code go for
it man dude smiley face
right side what do you think war is too
fast or what match okay so probably saw
that there's the second half so we can
blow this door down so we can get access
so hopefully my team shining contested
come on boys we've got to do it you need
to get into the best
[Music]
I ran out of bullets all right we're
getting push shofar back well we also
have an afk guy still a thing I don't
know how that guy had them to kicked yet
to be honest just stab him Faisal it
died
we got a minute
it might be okay if we can all get in
there
can't do anything they have it locked
rap
I'm trying genkai man I almost wanna
play again it's just like I'm so salty
that like group up and use your own I
need healing Jesus oh we only have four
people okay all that kind of makes some
sense that Chico guy didn't was like afk
since the first the first round what a
ridiculous turn of events well I got
second somehow
I guess we could have smoked em and one
to N
see how long it takes us if I can go
again maybe we just leave mid-match has
this to increase fall-off more range god
I was I felt so bad all right I want to
be on the assaulting team face no faze
clan face cleanse all right oh yes yes
redemption
we got a full squad oh we are in that in
that a
[Music]
get them all they're turning tail
where's the smoke grenade
we need them TAC what I'm so far away
usually you start closer to the like the
barn build that bridge doing it with no
freaking smoke good good
come on snipers
don't mind me just building a dammit
come on hammer faster bro dolphin dive
[Music]
yo our snipers need to snipe not be
building the bridge I'll build the damn
bridge just freakin snake I just got
collision nailed it
someone remind me to switch I got a with
remind myself to switch classes here a
second stop building that come on fine
that's fine they got a defuse it
where's my team oh shoot I forgot
Oh yet the flamethrower I think we're
good
tink I think we're good though I don't
think they're gonna get in there yeah I
did that and I got two kills get on the
take
oh what a shot Jordy what the hell is
the team
so they got to start building turrets oh
gosh
this is really hard to take
so far back push the payload we would I
would love a TiVo self-destruct
alright so the sniper is doing work I'm
just not going to enter the turret I'm
just going to protect
Wow they didn't get him the turrets I
wouldn't just camp the [ __ ] out of
Earth's nailed it
that's what a good team does right there
all right we're gonna if we have to play
the other side of it we'll play the
other side but yeah we'll see at least
in this mode you're like you know you
guys switch kind of classes play it
differently I know we're good we're good
5070 I'll take that it's pretty good
I think that should be yeah let's see I
don't think we'll have to play the other
half because I think it that was summary
too so yep cool that's a good way to go
out I feel like thank you uh ganky Kai
for suggesting there
appreciate y'all tuning in remember guys
GameSpot live is live every day at 11
a.m.
also if you haven't subscribed you
should do that because that will give
you guys notifications on when we do go
live also when we release some cool VOD
content for you guys we got reboot we
have history of as many as well as other
features reviews obviously news come
back next week Monday we have a holiday
in the u.s. here Labor Day of course but
Tuesday we're hoping somehow someway
that maybe we can stream destiny to no
idea if we can because US might not come
out till 9:00 but if we don't do that
we'll play something else Wednesday we
definitely will be streaming destiny too
we have a launch livestream with Randy
Couture if you guys know who that is
that's a UFC former champion also I
believe he's been in the expendable
movies so come back and tune in for that
and until next time thanks for tuning in
and see you guys next time peace happy
Friday
[Music]